Piers Morgan has said the horrible
things over the years. What do you have?
>> close to what Tucker Carlson has said
about Muslims, about Arabs, about What?
Are you serious? What Piers Morgan has
done is far worse than Tucker Carlson
and Candace Owens. He's been defending
what's going on and refusing to call it
a genocide.
Just to explain the gratitude and the
happiness that this
brother of ours is facing. Just 10
minutes ago he couldn't stand.
And alhamdulillah through your donations
to Waqf Forever, today not only is he
standing, but he has a smile on his
face. Jazakum Allahu khairan to each and
every one of you who dignified our
brother, our father from Gaza.
Donate to Waqf Forever and help change
lives today.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys are doing well,
inshallah. So, we're going to watch a
video from Mehdi Hasan and brother
Bassem Youssef. Um and I just found it a
little bit like Bassem Youssef felt a
bit um
intimidated, shall I say, from Mehdi
Hasan. Um and let's watch for ourselves
because I believe Mehdi Hasan, you know,
he's a very intelligent guy and he's
very good at debate. However, here it it
just his point seems very
um I found it silly. I found the
argument silly. Let's watch for
ourselves, inshallah. And is he right or
wrong in this matter? And there's ample
of evidence even he's a Shia himself to
his theology.
Um this this this argument this is, you
know, I'll go into this. You know, he's
a Shia and even when it comes to
committing a sin, uh let's alone someone
making a mistake or whatever for that
matter. Let's watch for ourselves,
inshallah, what his disagreement with
brother Bassem Youssef. Why don't you
like Candace Owens and Tucker Carlson?
Uh because they've said some horrific
things over the years. So so what? If I
was I'd be like
so what if they said horrific stuff?
They've said Many people have said
horrific stuff. What does that mean? You
can't change your ways, you can't change
the human being? I mean, you know, you
may have said something that you might
go back and be like, you know what? Um I
was completely wrong for for whatever it
might be. This is what people are going
to say, "Oh, you know, sorry you could
you
you know, we're not going to like you."
No, you Everyone makes mistakes. So
what? I mean I mean Why don't you like
Ben Shapiro? I mean I mean Ben What kind
of example is that? I don't understand.
Ben Shapiro has said,
you know, pro-genocide or something.
Let's suppose Tucker Carlson, which I
don't believe they have ever said that.
They've been
to an extent some more more more
morality on their side. But how could
you compare Ben Shapiro to Tucker
Carlson and Candace Owens? Uh as far as
I know they have been consistent when it
came to the killing of innocent men,
women, and children. They were They they
said this is where we draw the line. Ben
Shapiro does not draw that line. So, the
comparison is very is very silly. I
mean, for someone who's articulate, very
intelligent as Mehdi Hasan, I'm actually
very very surprised this argumentation
of his. Piers Morgan has said the
horrible things over the years. What do
you have?
>> anything close to what Tucker Carlson
has said about Muslims, about Arabs,
about immigrants,
>> And what? Come on, man. This guy is what
the what? Are you serious? I believe
what Piers Morgan has done is far worse
than Tucker Carlson and Candace Owens.
He's been defending what's going on and
refusing to call it a genocide. You
yourself interviewed Mehdi Hasan. So,
when it comes to Russia, he has one
rules when it comes to Israel, he has a
different set of rules.
Like I'm I'm I'm just here I'm just
thinking is this AI? Is this really
Mehdi Hasan? My surname is Z A T O or Z
T O, whatever it is.
It's from his actual Instagram. Could we
be strategic and use their platforms?
>> They can. Yeah, but like you
you don't like that. You No, it's not
that I don't like it. It's that my worry
is And you can use it. Allah says in the
Quran, you know,
in Surah Maidah,
"Wa ta'awanoo ala al-birri wa at-taqwa."
When it comes to, you know, come
together when it comes to righteousness.
And the Prophet came together in Hif
al-Fudul with the mushrikin. Who?
Mushrikin? You know, subhanallah because
a man was being wronged. So, I don't
know even to his theology in Shiism, you
know, I'm very sure that if someone
repents or changes their ways or
whatever says something, you give them a
chance. Like I don't understand this
attitude. I think it's more political
for that matter. I think it's a
political stance. Mehdi Hasan seems like
he's more politically loyal than
religiously. For the sake of one
important issue, Gaza is a huge issue.
Um we're giving a pass to these people
to launder some of their other
objectionable Like I said just now,
they're not disowning Trump. I Do you
see Do you see what I mean? Do you see
what I mean? They are talking about
something really important about because
of the political view, he doesn't like
them. He seems like he's more
politically loyal than he's more
religiously loyal. Do you know what I'm
trying to say or whatever or morally
whatever you want to call it. Just
because their political world view is
Donald Trump or whatever it is. So what?
Marjorie Taylor Greene, I'm going to go
home and take a shower after this. I
give her credit out of all of them
because she actually picked a fight with
Trump. She gave up her political career.
So, she actually put her money where her
mouth is to use a phrase. The rest of
Tucker doesn't say a single anti-Trump
word. He acts like the war in Iran came
down from the skies. We wouldn't be in
this war in Iran had Tucker not promoted
Trump for president. Had Candace not
promoted Trump for president. Had Megan
Kelly not promoted Trump for president.
We're in this war. Joe Rogan, Theo Von,
all these guys. Did you watch Joe and
Theo the other day saying that terrorist
Israel. I can't believe we're in this
war. You guys gave us Trump. You said I
Yeah, but how does that make them wrong?
They thought that Trump was going I'm
genuinely bamboozled. I mean, I should
have I didn't read Mehdi Hasan's thing
of how to win a debate every time.
Without reading it, I think I've
In this In this specific thing, I think
I could debate him and tell him that he
is absolutely wrong when this debate,
you know, without reading his book, you
know, how to win a debate against Mehdi
Hasan without reading his book. Yeah,
okay. To make it authentic or even use
use his own arguments against him. How
does that make sense? You know, at the
end of the day, so what if they've done
that? They've They were lied to. Trump
said we're not going to go to war and
look, you know, the whole Epstein files
and them raping little children and then
being blackmailed with it and being
forced I'm not taking blame off Trump.
But come on, how are you having a quad
them if they've changed their views and
said, "Okay, we were scammed." Kamala
Harris is going to do war, Trump is
anti-war. How did that work out?
>> I think it's all an act. Well, whatever
it is, they got their act and well
they're actually not they're doing very
well and they're reaching a lot of
people and they're affecting a lot of
people.
>> But but they're affecting badly. I could
argue that Joe Rogan helped Donald Trump
win. So, Joe Rogan is the reason we're
in the war in Iran. If I wanted to I'm
just saying if I took that argument to
its logical conclusion. Do you think Joe
Rogan would actually would help
like that the Democrats? They would they
wouldn't No, again Joe Rogan, yes, did
help Trump argument's sake or whoever,
but at the end of the day when he was
wrong um they they're calling him out.
So, he was like, "If you come and give
me a promise and I
believe you and then you go back on your
word, how is that my fault?" like stand
up for his What What was What was her
name? Kamala Harris. Oh, I She's
useless. He was a Bernie guy once, but
then he he got red-pilled. She's She's
useless.
She's
She's that useless. Like I can't even
remember her name. But you missed my
point. My point is these people helped
give us Trump and that's why I have a
problem with it because they don't I
only respect the people who own it. If
you're Marjorie Taylor Greene and you
say, "I was wrong about Trump. I was
wrong about my Fine. Right? But if
you're like acting, "Hey, how did this
all happen? This war in Iran is bad. I
can't believe they're doing it. Hey, it
happened cuz you told people falsely
that Trump would be anti-war."
>> So what's your point?
My point is you asked me why I don't
like them. I'm telling you why. I'm so
sorry. It's I feel like Bassem Youssef
there was
You see when someone's a good debater,
sometimes you're like, "Oh, you need to
be careful. He might catch me out." So,
Bassem Youssef didn't seem as confident
as he is. And why? Because of Mehdi's
reputation. But his arguments were all
weak. All weak. So, sometimes you
shouldn't let that overtake you in that
sense where you have this perception
like this person is a good debater. So
what? Truth is the truth and the truth
will smash falsehood like Allah says in
the Quran. The point is this, guys,
subhanallah, in a nutshell, that this
argument like imagine someone like for
example someone is Sahaba, companions,
yes,
may have called people to commit shirk
before becoming a Muslim and then they
become a Muslim. What are you going to
say? "Oh, because of you people are
carrying on worshipping idols." Yeah,
I've changed I've repented. Sorry, I was
wrong. I don't Can I not be wrong? Like
come on. Like Mehdi, I'll be honest with
you I'm I'm I'm a bit taken aback of
this argumentation that you have. And
Candace Owens and Tucker Carlson and
Lady Megan, etc., they are all exposing
Israel. And if anything we should ally
with them. It's as simple as that. Till
next time. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.